Apple's iPhone 15 Pro comes with a huge
new a17 Pro chip upgrade and to be
completely honest I was initially very
disappointed with Apple's lackluster
claims of only 10 Single core and 20
graphics performance gains over last
year's a16 but we just got some brand
new leaked benchmarks that show that
Apple was drastically underestimating
The Real World app and game performance
that we should actually expect and in
this video I'll go through those League
scores and explain what to expect why
we're seeing those numbers and what it
means for you it seems like apple is
going the route of setting expectations
low and exceeding them because their
initial 10 Single core performance gain
was very disappointing with initial
benchmarks showing a 9.3 gain being the
lowest gain in the history of Apple's a
series iPhone chips but then out of
nowhere another leaked geekman 6 score
showed up with a huge gain showing a 1
mapping single core score of 299 which
represents a very impressive 19
Improvement but then after that more and
more League scores kept pouring in and
it seems like we're landing at an
average of around
2850 points and single core leading to a
more modest 13 gain which is still okay
and a bit better than what Apple quoted
now in terms of multi-core performance
this one's a bit weird because the
initial scores sat at around 7 192
points which is a fairly weak 10.5 gain
compared to the a16 but then it shot up
to a high of
779 which gives us a nice 22 gain but
since then we've been seeing scores
around 7 300 which will give us a 14
boost which is also okay considering we
have the same core layout as before and
then getting into Graphics Apple initial
claim of a 20 graphics performance boost
was quite low considering the fact that
they added one extra GPU core which is
essentially 20 more course this
basically shows that Apple didn't
actually have to improve graphics
performance at all on a per core basis
they could have simply added another
identical a16 GPU core and called it
good which is why I was so disappointed
which leads me to this brand new leaked
Benchmark that proves me wrong but first
I've got to show you this the new ice
mag power bank from our sponsor charge
which you definitely need if you want to
truly take advantage of the new a17 Pro
chips performance for things like gaming
the ice mag is the world's first
magnetic power bank with active fan
cooling making it perfect for charging
while gaming so you simply place it on
the back of your iPhone using macsafe
and the high capacity 10 1000 milliamp
hour battery pack will charge your
iPhone while the 8 000 RPM fan keeps it
cool so it doesn't slow down which you
can actually see through the Sleek
transparent design with Dynamic RGB
lighting and if you need faster charging
it can also output a huge 20 watts of
power with the included USBC to C cable
which is perfect for the new iPhone 15s
and you can order it today using the
link in the description below now
getting back to the new leaked
benchmarks gfx bench has long been a
reliable Benchmark that shows the gaming
performance we should expect from modern
tech devices and in the Aztec Ruins
normal tier off-screen test the a17 pro
Chip gave us a whopping 45 boost
compared to the a16 which is a huge gain
and totally unexpected when you look at
Apple's claim of a 20 gain now it wasn't
that good in every test as some of them
like man Patton showed a 31.5 gain and
some being 27 like in the Aztec Ruins
High tier but still these are better
Real World results than we expected so
if you're trying to make sense of how
there's such a big performance disparity
between Apple's claims and what we're
seeing here I think there are a couple
of good reasons for it reason number one
is that Apple seems to be used bench six
as their Graphics Benchmark for
comparisons and we actually just got
League scores for that as well based on
a bunch of these scores it seems like
the average middle score is around 27
400 points for the a17 pro which gives
us a gain of around 23 which isn't bad
at all but nowhere near the gains we got
in gfx bench so maybe the geekbench
graphics test isn't as optimized yet and
the current 6.2 version now reason
number two is that all of those extra
GPU upgrades that Apple mentioned might
not impact the RAW graphics powered
numbers in benchmarks as much as they do
in actual real world game performance
which is much better simulated in gaming
benchmarks like gfx bench and 3D Marks
Wildlife extreme that actually sounds a
whole lot more reasonable to me because
these new GPU changes could be more on
the back end which greatly help with
gaming efficiency and optimization sort
of like how Apple's unified memory
architecture helped a ton for gaming
performance on the M series Mac chips
compared to Intel now if you don't know
which new a17 Pro GPU changes I'm
talking about let me explain them the
first one is metal FX which was
previously limited to Apple's M1 and M2
chips but now it's supported on the a17
pro it's basically a new API that game
developers can use to greatly improve
the performance of a game at higher
resolutions like 4K by simply upscaling
1080p to simulated 4K in real time
making it look similar to Native 4K
resolution without the need for a ton of
Graphics power which would usually cause
low frame rate performance for example
in quality mode it gave an M1 Max 14
inch MacBook Pro a 35 boost in fps up to
a playable 70 FPS in Resident Evil
Village but in performance mode it more
than doubled the FPS up to 111
outperforming an RTX 3070 graphics card
metal effects actually utilizes the
neural engine which is now two times
more powerful than before so that's
actually going to help the GPU out a lot
the a17 pro now also includes mesh
shaders with a new GPU Shader
architecture which essentially optimizes
the pipeline of Graphics shading
combining multiple steps from a
traditional GPU pipeline into less tasks
or steps which basically improves
graphics performance making the GPU use
less power thanks to being more
efficient and then finally the a17 pro
has dedicated Hardware Ray tracing cores
which boost Ray tracing performance by
four times finally allowing the iPhone
15 Pro to run an incredibly good looking
AAA games for the first time ever which
Apple says is basically console gaming
levels of performance so with all that
said what does this mean well it means
that with these announcements apple is
officially entering the AAA game market
and sending a message to game makers
that they should start supporting Apple
silicon including the iPhone the iPad
and the Mac which by the way we now know
will be getting all of the huge upgrades
in Ray tracing with the M3 line of chips
it also means the iPhone will be known
as the best phone in the world for
gaming offering the best quality and
most consistent frame rates starting now
which will make it very hard for other
Android phone makers to compete so
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did subscribe above for our launch
Day videos and definitely check out the
charge I smack battery pack with active
Cooling using the link below and
definitely check out one of those two
videos over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]